can you unpack the level of
how addictive these opioids are when
somebody starts so walk me through what
the process is and where it goes next so
hey typically it's a doctor gives it to
them walk me through the process this is
your world that you research what does
that really look like
well what i would i want to maybe back
up just a little bit here okay
what is certainly true is that um
three out of four people who who
three to four four to five seventy five
to eighty percent that's about roughly
like who move on to heroin began
uh their use of opiates with a
prescription and
uh and i i would also like maybe
quantify or push back a little bit on
misuse
um
what happens with opioids is that
these are pharma pharmaceutical
these molecules mimic the own opioids we
make okay we have receptors for these
okay but our brains are built for
physiologic doses small ones
and then we're getting pharmaceutical
doses
big ones okay
and the brain naturally pushes back the
brain doesn't want to feel elation and
euphoria all the time it pushes back
almost immediately and says this is not
normal
and what we know is that very quickly
when you start exposing yourself to
opioids is your brain starts to change
and it stops responding to them and it
actually develops these processes called
opponent processes where they don't work
so well and there was a very important
study done in 2016 by the kaiser
foundation in the washington post that
shows people who are exposed to opioids
report becoming dependent or addicted in
as little as two months that's how fast
it works
so it's not so much that they are
misusing them what they're finding is
that they are being told they work for
pain and then very quickly find out well
one isn't working for pain anymore now i
need two for pain now i need five for
pain and so let's it can be better
character this is natural
physiologic homeostasis and what
homeostasis means in medicine biology is
that the body wants stability
so
these medicines are are not working like
they were supposed to because the body
is pushing back and so that's what
happens when a person again like your
friends starts it out for tooth pain and
one was fine now they need three
and it hijacks the brain's own opioid
system your own reward system gets
hijacked by these chemicals
such that now
you make almost no opioid yourself your
endorphins with your natural opioids
stop getting made the brain is pushing
back on their effect and so now when you
are without them
your brain says i feel awful do
something
and so that might have led to that
episode where your friend is begging
because they were in in pure
misery
because the molecule that everyone sort
of almost takes for granted you've got a
regular amount of it keeping you feeling
normal that that feeling of normal is
gone
and that's how dangerous and how how
destructive they can be that in as
little as two months
you can change the brain enough to
become dependent so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]